we're joined here in the studio by Alexi
goncharenko a Ukrainian MP with a seat
in Odessa which of course has come under
ongoing attack very nice to have you in
the studio Alexi
um in terms of what's happening in these
four disputed regions there have been
these referendums that we we should put
inverted commas around yeah so-called
here
um and Russia is now going to amalgamate
these areas into its own country
tomorrow how do you feel about that and
how hard is it watching that happen
it's new crime from Putin nothing new
for us so we knew that that is his
Playbook and he is coming to you through
it and realizing it but for us nothing
has changed and this is our territories
This Is Our Land this is our people and
we should liberate them and we have many
reasons for this but one reason is that
people on occupied territories are on
the genocide and it's not uh political
like expression but a juridical one
because according to United Nations
convention and prevention of genocide
there are five criteria of genocide and
even if one is met it's already genocide
but unfortunately in Ukraine all five
are met on the occupied territories we
have public speeches of Putin that
ukrainians as a group do not exist this
is just bad Russians who should be fixed
uh destroy they destroy our cultural
heritage forceful deportation of people
including children to make from them
Russians sexual crimes and mass murders
everything everything is on the table so
we can't leave these people on the
genocide so we should liberate them and
we will do it
and there is obviously that that clear
belief and desire to do this the fact
that these areas will be Amalgamated
tomorrow but we've seen what happened in
Crimea
not so many years ago do you feel
confident now that not only will you be
able to take these four areas back but
you'll be able to take Crimea back as
well I think we should liberate all our
territories including for sure Crimea
which is Ukraine and this is the only
way to come back to International order
and to international law to respective
international law if the situation will
go another way if Putin would be
successful in any way that will mean
that we don't have a world with the
order in it with international law this
will be the world like a wild jungles
with a beer with a tiger hiding hunting
for peaceful Nations that shouldn't be
this way so that's why we believe that
we can liberate all our territories and
we already showed it like just several
weeks ago a liberated part of harkev
region which was like one third of it
was also occupied that is like more than
one thousand square miles and we
liberated it just in several days so it
we hope that we will continue to do it
and I can tell you that our
counter-offensive has not stopped we
continue with every daily berate Town
Village some territory in the east of
our country and also in the south
in terms of what happens next we know
that that President Putin is talking
tough about what will happen he's talked
about conscripting people inside Russia
to go to the front line we've seen
Russian men trying to leave the country
and today we've seen that Finland is
saying it's closing its borders to
Russian tourists
um in terms of of what possibly is on
the horizon do you fear it's going to
get a great deal worse before it gets
better
first of all I would like to tell you
that this mobilization that cannot
change the result of the war but that
can certainly prolong the war and that
will be a new Bloodshed and tens of
thousands of people killed why it will
not change the result of the war because
Russian army and Russian state is like a
dinosaurus or a very big body tiny head
and very tiny brains inside so the
problem of Russian army is not the size
of the body number of people but in
other problems and they do not fix them
with the mobilization but now and I
understand that and I understand that
you you know ukrainians are fighting for
something that they believe in
absolutely the Russians are conscripted
that they are not necessarily but is
that self-belief and that desire to save
the country enough to actually save it I
think yes but uh also I want to tell you
that I think now we have a unique window
of opportunity like in Ukraine if you in
March if we would have weaponry that we
have today hi Mars is hovisers and other
things we would finish everything in
spring when Russians were retreating
from Kiev designs the blitzkrik failed
now we have new window of opportunity
these new mobilized people will arrive
in two months probably and before these
I think one two big defeats like near
harkiv and Putin's regime will will
collapse that is absolutely real but for
these we need to receive two demo
Weaponry from the West long-range
missiles tanks finally because for the
moment we haven't received any one
modern Western tank so that should be
made and with this we can finish
everything before this newly mobilized
will arrive and that will be in the
benefit of the whole world and very
briefly because we only have 30 seconds
left but new sanctions do you think that
they they will will come and you think
they will make a difference sure they
should be finally to cut Russia from
Swift sanctions against Dermatology
which is still not under sanctions and
many other things which can be and
should be done first of all against gas
and oil